[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello I'm David Kaplan and this is in
theory what do we know about the earth
well surprisingly little we do know that
the continents drift
there are plate tectonics that cause
features on the surface but we don't
know exactly why that occurs and we
don't know why it doesn't occur on other
planet the way scientists are going to
learn about the process that created the
earth is by getting evidence for the
entire solar system how is the Sun and
the other planets created as well so
here's what we know and how we know it
at the beginning we believe the solar
system started as a gas cloud that moved
around the galaxy and at some point a
star nearby exploded it sent a shock
that ripple causes the gas does
gravitationally collapse forming the Sun
and a protoplanetary disk around it
[Music]
during the first hundred thousand years
of this solar system the dust is
colliding into each other and creating
little clumps this is called the primary
accretion stage and by the end of the
hundred thousand years the
kilometer-sized rock is enough to
accrete or gather additional material
allowed to grow that continues on for
roughly ten million years the inner part
of the solar system has rocky
planetesimals becoming planet embryos
whereas the outer planets are becoming
much bigger it's colder out there and so
when the dust and clumps hit each other
they attach more easily so things are
more efficient and grow bigger
[Music]
the next hundred million years is the
giant impact stage that's when much
larger objects are colliding with each
other the planetesimals are really
forming and becoming the planets that we
know and love with roughly four rocky
planets in the interior two gas giants
Jupiter and Saturn and two ice giants
Uranus and Neptune a right in the middle
of there there's at 60 million years we
believe the moon was formed and the
current theory is that a object the size
of Mars crashes into the earth knocks
some debris off of it and a very hot
molten goop stays in orbit around the
earth that goop cools into a spherical
object and becomes the moon so part of
that impact stage was also the creation
of the Earth Moon system for the next
600 million years we go through a late
accretion stage where you have Pluto
like objects crashing into the earth and
to the other planets and depositing
metal you see metal which is a very
heavy element sinks towards the center
but in a late accretion stage if
something hits the earth metal can be
deposited at the surface and so the
trace elements different metals that we
discover today are because of that stage
there's some speculation that a lot of
violence occurred between six and eight
hundred million years that Jupiter and
Saturn migrated their way towards the
inner planets cleared out a lot more of
the rocks and other stuff and then
eventually migrated back out during that
stage other interesting things could
have hit the earth like comets carrying
water explaining the existence of water
on earth at roughly 1.6 billion years
all that heat in the core tries is
trying to escape the earth and the
additional radioactive elements are
heating it even more that heat plays two
important roles it allows activity in
the core like spinning and the molten
metal to remain there and it is probably
the source of the strong magnetic fields
on the earth it's also important because
as the heat tried to escape it broke up
the continents it broke up the surface
of the earth and created the tectonic
plates those plates then began to move
due to the heat and created all kinds of
interesting things and motion of the
continents themselves much later other
things formed at the crust all that heat
coming out may be created these mantle
plumes which add additional volcanoes
create hot spots like Yellowstone
National Park
we don't have exact dates for all of
that activity but that's a sort of rough
picture that we think is going on all of
those things that tectonic plates the
magnetic fields the moon they just turn
out to be incredibly important things
for life on Earth
they make earth a very nice place for
organic material like us we don't know
why but as we try to figure it out
we learn what are the properties
necessary to create an earth-like planet
and that's very important as we're
searching for other planets within the
galaxy but it's also part of our story
it's part of the story of what created
us and so this period which is messy and
complicated is worth understanding
because it tells the entire picture of
how we came to be I'm David Kaplan and
this has been in theory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]